那个时隔两周没和大家见面了
那这两周同学们过得怎么样
那个希望大家这个马上要开学了对吧
然后大家都能够顺利的返回学校
那么暑假呢总是这个过得非常的快
而且今年暑假有个很大的特点
就是特别特别的热
真的我从来没见过这么热的暑假
那么所以的话呢那我们的课程的话呢
其实也进入到我们的尾声
也就是最后三节课
也就是我们的高级课
那那么这里面的话呢其实也是我们开始逐渐去有时间去思考
我们的小伙伴们现在学的怎么样
大家进入这个课程有没有什么困难
所以今天的话呢我们首先跟大家讲一下
我们现在课程组跟同学们交流下来
我们决定要做的几件事
第一件事情的话呢就是说实际上这个课程大家如果能真的跟下来
实际上是非常非常的挑战的
那么所以的话呢我们觉得确实就是要给同学们发一个证书对吧
那么就是根据同学们完成的情况
那我们课程组呢也会很认真的去那个根据同学们提交上来的作业
然后给同学们打分
然后呢就是如果大家做的都是对的
我们给大家60分
如果做的非常好的话
是100分
就所有的点全部实现了
那个我们当时作业的要求
所以的话呢如果就是说同学们每一个作业的话都做了
而且都能够及格的话
我们认为应该给大家发一个
这个就是成功的毕业于game 104课程的这样的一个一个一个证书
那么如果同学们如果有两个作业能达到100分的话
我们认为是非常优秀的
那我们要给大家的这个就是不一样的
就是excellent
那如果大家真的三三门作业做的都是满分的话
那我觉得一定是非常的outstanding了
所以这件事情的话实际上啊非常了非常有意思啊
就是我自己想想
要是我到时候毕业的时候找工作的时候
诶
我game 4204课程我真的学完了游戏引擎
然后我而且我还拿到了all standing的话
嗯反正我觉得这个工作应该是蛮好找的对吧
这个好像说的很现实啊
今天找工作还是非常挑战
然后的话呢就希望大家一起多多加油
多多努力
那么其实104课程的话呢
我觉得教的很多东西还真的是在就是游戏行业
甚至游戏行业之外都是蛮有用的一个东西
所以我自己也是蛮开心的
就是随着小引擎啊
随着这个课程的话
同学们都说诶
教的这些东西能够帮助大家能够这个更快的适应自己的行业的需求
这个诶我觉得不错
挺棒的
然后呢另外一个课程组的话
我们肯定要鼓励大家去好好这个这个做作业了
对不对
那但我们也很穷对吧
我们也没有太多的东西可以奖励大家
那我们怎么办呢
我们想了想嗯给大家
那个我们的t恤我们多印几件
就是所有的同学大家只要做完了这个我们的作业的
我们就是全部做完了
而且60分以上我们成功毕业了
我们课程组就送给大家一些t恤吧
也是留作一个纪念
因为这半年能够坚持下来
其实真的非常的不容易
我自己讲的已经是累得要死要活了
今天他们说我的眼睛都肿了对吧
那但是的话呢我觉得其实大家能坚持学下来也是非常的怎么说呢
非常的厉害
我觉得这真的是一种人生的考验和体验吧
那么然然后呢
因为考虑到好多同学刚刚进入到我们的课程呢
后面的话我们也会想办法给大家更多的帮助
所以的话呢我们想这次作业交的时间的话
不一定要等课程结束
我们的课程大概在9月中下旬就最后一节课能讲完
104讲完哎
大家是不是有点舍不得
反正我有点舍不得大家啊
虽然说每每每次都很累
但是每周跟大家来讲一讲我们的东西
那么那我们的作业的话呢
就是说我们想把它设在就是呃10月底给大家有更多的时间去完成作业
而且课程那个时候没有那么紧张的时候
大家有什么困难啊
或者题目不知道怎么做的话
像我们的课程组的小伙伴去那个求助
然后呢我们尽可能给大家帮助
争取我们能够拿到毕业证书的同学越多越好对吧
这个我也会很有成就感
那么这是第一件事儿
那第二件事情的话呢
就是哎呀这个是这个是我们欠大家很久的一个东西了
就是我们的皮克罗引擎
其实现在一直在开发
然后的话接近过段时间可能会有一个比较大的update
上面给大家讲到的就是我们还是比较丧心病狂的
比如说我们会做gpu particle
做一个版本进去了
我们甚至还在想把他那个rh那一层整个重新设计一遍
让它做得更漂亮一点
这个就作为程序员嘛
有的时候一旦代码开写了
你会忍不住不断的把它写得更好
但是呢我们课程的很多同学就是说这个引擎很棒
但是我看不懂怎么办对吧
那些代码为什么这么架构
比如说大家一直想了解的
比如说我那个反射是怎么做的
对不对
那实际上呢我们就在这个地方立一个flag吧
就是等我们把104课程忙完之后
我们争取在10月10号我们开始这个flag立在这了
就是我们开始跟同学们去讲解一下我们的这个pico的引擎
我们也尝试去回答一下
那么就是说呢因为那个尤里斯课程结束之后
大家可能很难找到我们了
我们当然我们有自己的这个就是呃那个那个就是我们的b站上
好像是有个视频账号的吧
是我好像叫叫我的名字
然后但是的话呢就是说呃同学们也可以关注我们的微信公众号
我们专门为po这个课程做了一个微信公众号
大家可以扫到那个旁边的二维码
加入到我们的那个就是呃微信公众号里面
然后大家在里面选择点击那个入群啊
点击那个入群之后呢
输入入群之后可以进到我们104课程的各个微信群里面
这样的话我们如果后面有代码解读啊
这些东西我们就把这些资料分享给大家
有什么问题也可以告诉我们
就是说我们还挺希望就是说这个pico的效应器
我们一起合力把它做的越做越有趣对吧
就是将来以后变成我们大家这个毕设的这个标配
那就太棒了对吧
人人手一个游戏引擎
就这么实现的对吧
其实我们都基于plog folk一个出来
所以说这个是啊就是10月10号我们争取能够开始启动了一件事吧
但那个时候不一定是我了
可能是我们的课程组的
后面的无数的这个无名英雄跟我们一起来做这件事情好
那么第三件事情的话呢
就是哎回答一下上一节课同学们问我们的一些问题啊
我今天看到这些问题的时候
我的第一反应就是我已经严重怀疑我们课程组是不是真的
这个筛出来是我们同学们问的问题
因为这些问题问的实在是太专业了对吧
第一个问题相对来讲还比较回答好回答
就同学问我说诶这个就是到底游戏有没有可能去反作弊对吧
怎么能不能彻底解决它啊
这件事情的答案就是至少我目前知道的肯定是no搞不定的
因为这玩意儿真的是道高一尺
魔高一丈
就是说这也是全世界所有的online gaming的一个极其头疼的问题
就是其实有很多种解决方法
首先从技术上来讲的话
你可以通过加密啊
通过各种方法来解决它
对不对
但是就像我讲的
就是无论你用什么方法
总有人能破解
那么接下来呢你还有方法什么的
就是你从设计上就尽量避免就是别人去作弊的时候
他能够获益
那其实在比如说像有的游戏
它的彻底是放在服务器判定的
这当然是一种解法
但是它会影响手感对吧
它不再用本地的物理或者其他东西来解决
它实际上是用那个就是其他的一些更多的可控制的
这种机制来进行判定
那么其实呢我自己个人觉得还有一个很有意思的方法
就是说诶采取这种这个这种很奇怪的这种社交化的方法去打个例子
比如举个例子啊
比如说像vac对吧
就是那个那个steam上的那个反作弊的那个方法
他的做法是什么样的
但是说诶你只要在一个产品里面被那个游戏的发现了
你作弊了
我给你报到vc去
那你整个steam账号可能都要受影响
我想想看
我stea上那么多的游戏对吧
我要是在一个就是你们做了b导致了我那一串游戏都不能玩了
我想想打死我也不作弊了
我觉得这个可能是一个很好的方法了对吧
所以但是简简单来讲的话
就是说其实在游戏里面
反作反作弊是一个很长期的一个艰苦卓绝的斗争
那么他是要持续的去不断更新
而且呢我一直认为它不是一个纯技术的问题
它实际上还需要就是说我们和社区一起
玩家一起来
就是说联动去解决和发现这些问题
所以啊它永远是个动态的平衡
那么第二个问题呢
这个问题就非常的专业了
他说唉请这个说一下
就是微服务和分布式的服务器架构到底有什么区别
其实呢差两个不是区别的关系
我个人理解啊
什么意思呢
分布式的服务器架构呢是一个标准的
也是最经典的一个服务器的选择方法
它相对于就是说你把所有的这个业务写到一个进山里面去了对吧
那你就不是分布式的
那分布式的意思就是说我会在多台物理机
用多个进程或者是线程协同去工作
然后呢每个人各司其职就完成工作
但是这种这种分布式呢它的一个架构可以很多种
比如说我们可以把数据库的访问和游戏逻辑分开了
对不对
那我们在游戏里面开很多战局对吧
那我每一个战局我会形成形成一个独立的game server
那你只要把一个整个游戏世界的业务分成一个一个的这个单独的进程
或者是现成的话
那这就是叫做分布式的这个游戏的这个这个server arc architecture对吧
但是呢microservice呢它其实是一种设计理念
它我认为是分布式那个服务器架构的一种实现方法
他是讲的一种思想是什么呢
就是说诶我会把这些这个就是说这个服务器在后台的一些东西
拆成尽可能干净和单一的我们的一个业务的实施单元
那比如说邮件聊天对吧
用户登录
比如说房间的匹配等等
都有了变成独立的服务
那么这些服务的话呢
它其实呢microservice的一个点
就是最早期的microservice都是尽量争取是无状态的
就是希望诶我可以很容易地对他进行扩容啊
对它进行这个减负啊
因为我要支持弹性的变化嘛
另外一个点是什么呢
就是说哎一旦有些服务一旦出了问题之后
诶
我可以通过那个服务发现对吧
我会发现这些问题
同时的话我会再去spa更多的这个服务出来
所以呢它是一种就是说非常好的基于容器的一种这个服务器的分布式
服务器系统的一种实现方式
那么这里面无所谓高下吧
其实就如果大家真的去研究一下
就是啊现代online game的这个游戏那个服务器架构的话呢
它也不是完全的microservice
它有些服务它是用mc service的架构去做的
但有些东西的话呢
它还是要全局的进行
这个就是说自己去管理自己服务
所以这件事情的话呢
就像我一直在讲
就是当大家真的开始在做有性情的时候
千万不要纠结于某些具体的概念
一直要强调就是甜豆浆
咸豆浆到底哪个好
实际上是适合你这个snl的
就是你最好的方案
那么第三个问题呢
哎呀那就是那就太难了
这个问题我觉得同学们
我们说诶如何构建一个就是全球能够联网对战的这样一个战斗系统
那这个问题要是真的大家能回答的清楚的话
基本上你到很多的这个游戏的大厂里面
可以申请一些比较资深的开发者的这个职位了
确实这个事儿啊
问的还是挺挑战的
因为全球联网的这样的一个这个battle game
就是或者说这个开房间的这个游戏的话
技术上还是有蛮多挑战的
因为这里面有比较大的一些挑战吗
比如说全球的这个物理连接的延迟对吧
你这么多的节点来回
他怎么去延迟
这么简单来讲的话呢
实际上第一个你的服务器可能是要进行分布式架构的
就是说在世界各地它都有各种各样的服务器
那这些服务器之间的话呢
你要建立它的高速通讯
那么这里面的话一个简单的做法就是说你可以给他们加一些
就是我称为叫这个high speed
那个那个那个主干线就是高速的那个干线
让你的全球各个机房之间
它是走专线
通讯速度要足够快
当然了
你再快也快不过光速
对不对
但这里面有个小有意思的小细节
就是说我们比如说从一个地方
比如说中国连接到美国
或者从中国连接到欧洲
这个中间最大的延迟来自于什么地方呢
实际上并不是光传播的速度
光传播速度过去了
也就是差不多
如果没记错
应该也差不多也就100ms左右吧
或者是还不到
但它真正慢在什么地方呢
是无数次的网关路由
就是说诶这个地方不停的转发转发
转发转发这个地方会导致很多的延迟
所以的话呢实际上就是如果你真的要做这种全球联网的游戏的话
那是一个很花钱的事
因为你要在世界各地
要么就购买
要么自己建设这种专用的机房
机房之间用那个光纤尽可能直接连起来
当然这里面有些虚拟的这种叫做那个专用通道
这其实有很多的这个就是通讯服务商提供这样的服务
那么同时的吗
还有一个技术呢
就是说哎比如说我在欧洲对吧
欧洲的用户是来自于各地
他们不要直接连你的服务器
其实你可以提供一些他们本地更方便的这些节点给大家举个例子吧
比如说如果你要去服务南美玩家
大家可能看到南美洲是一块大洲
对不对
但是南美洲你看它的西侧有个国家叫治理
特别的长
然后那个山好像是应该是那个忘了哪个山很很长的
就是全世界最长有1万多公里
就是从北美洲一路贯穿下来到南美洲那个山
那个山的左边和右边的话
虽然大家都在南美洲
但是它的网络是非常隔绝的
所以说你他那些国家连接
可能亚洲的速度都比连接套那个那个那个大陆的另外一边的速度要快
所以说当你要去服务南美洲这样的一个一个一个世界的时候
你实际上在那个区域要做很多专门的处理的
你的服务器到底架在墨西哥还是阿根廷对吧
你千万不要加到智力取
那然后呢你跟北美到底是直接连接
还是通过其他的方式
这里面就有一些很有意思的问题了
这个里面的话呢就下次有机会给大家详细讲
其实非常好玩
就是你可以看到全世界的这个网络的图图图谱
所以说这个问题的回答呢
其实从它的概念层面上来讲还是不是很复杂的
但是呢你真的去实施它的时候
你发现你还真的需要知道全球的这个高速的光纤的分布图对
所以说这个问题是我这个问题的答案好
那我们今天那个就是前面给大家的那个闲话就讲到这儿了
就是这个d o p dorange program programming
面向数据编程和job sim
但是我实际讲的顺序可能是倒过来的
因为我今天在写这一趴的时候
我发现哇这里面的概念真的特别特别的多
然后这也是大家很期待很久的
因为什么呢
因为这些都是现在特别时髦的一些概念
那今天的话呢我的责任就是尽可能用大家都能懂的语言给大家讲清楚
这里面的这个基础的想法和思想是什么
具体的s d k啊
什么东西
大家可以自己去查对吧
好
那我现在来挑战一下
看看能不能用这个简单的语言
让大家有大学cs的基础
就能听得懂这两个比较前沿的这个游戏引擎开发的理念好
首先给大家讲一下
就是为什么要做这件事情
实际上的话呢在现代游戏引擎
它实际上是跑在我们这一代的各种各样的操作系统上面
而操作系统呢又是跑在各种各样的意见上面
所以说呢其实游戏引擎最大的特点是什么
就是我们对performance要求非常高对吧
但是我们的带宽也是有限的
我们的这个算力也是有限的
那你想我们在1/30秒啊
我们要完成大量的这种物理的这个逻辑的运算对吧
物理的模拟还有什么
我还要一瞬间炫出那种就是几百万
是上千万个像素里面无数的光的反射积分
这些东西大家记得我们在rendering那一刻讲了
那天那些运算
大家觉得是不是很恐怖对吧
那我们后面讲到物理呀
讲到游戏逻辑啊
讲到一大堆这种动画这些系统的时候
大家想想这些都是不是很恐怖
这个对算力的要求都太高了
但是呢游戏引擎还挺恐怖的
为什么诶
所以我1/30秒全部得算完诶结果我们的游戏玩家说我不满意
我要60帧啊
60帧感觉还不对
我要打电竞
我要120帧好了吗
这个游戏引擎就疯掉了
我我怎么样才能够对吧
这个这个臣妾做不到这么高的要求
我就这么一个cpu
我怎么做到
所以说其实当我们在设计游戏引擎的时候
我们实际上是需要把操作系统
把硬件的所有的性能几乎压榨到极限
这就是为什么所有的这个就是重型游戏团队或者是引擎团队的话
基本上都是游戏的这个这个硬件和操作系统性能的这个大师
就是这个道理
那么今天的话呢我们先从第一拍开始讲起
就是这个并行编程
epio programming对吧
其实写到这一part的时候
我我当时准备这个课程的时候
我跟我们的课程组的小伙伴
我们就一边准备
一边在笑
为什么呢
因为我这一趴说实话让我回想起了
我在大学上这个操作系统这门课的时候
我印象我上这门课的时候
那个老师啊年纪很大
是一个很一个老教授
每次敷这个眼镜
然后这样看着我们我们这么厚的一本教材
然后每次我听他的课听得都昏昏欲睡
然后全部就忘了
然后考完试之后基本上全还给他了
但是呢当我们去准备这个power program programming的时候
我发现哎呀哇老教授讲的所有的东西我又全部回想起来了
但我今天尽量不要切换到老教授模式
我还是用这个很简单的语言
争取把这个并行编程的一些有意思的东西给大家讲清楚
因为它这个东西就是我们讲的job system的基础
就是首先的话第一点的话就是为什么要并行编程对吧
那其实这就是一个事实
就是说其实随着现在的晶体管
就是现在的那个就是集成电路的工艺
已经almost hit到它的那个量子力学的上限了
大家都知道我们现在在做吐人类的突破
22nm
对不对
将来以后好像理论极限是0.5nm
但是这个应该是几乎不可能了对吧
再往下1nm
那接下来再怎么上呢
也上不去了
对不对
那那怎么办
其实我们可以看到
在过去几年
如果大家经常买电脑的人
就知道就是好像这个核是越堆越多
但是呢主频现在基本上三点几个赫兹就上不去了吧
我我们我们团队有一个就是英特尔送给我们的那个主频
可以冲到四点几
但是那那个那个声音已经是基本上有点吓人了
所以说事实上的话呢
就是啊我们的整个processor已经到了他的一个理论的上限了
就是说我们再往上冲的话
无论是散热也好
功耗也好
都有很大的问题
所以这个问题的解决方法是什么呢
就是说哎我既然不能够把这个盒越做越快
那我能不能用更多的核解决这个问题
所以今天大家买电脑的话
什么四核八核16核已经是它的常态了
那么当我们有这么多的核之后
实际上呢我们必然呢就要想办法
就是能够把这些和的算力全部利用起来
那这里面在传统的操作系统里面
诶我们大家很熟悉的两个概念就是a进程和线程对吧
大家还记得进城和县城有什么区别对吧
我当时上操作系统课的时候
老教授这第一个问我的问题就是诶这个是什么问题对吧
哦我们就说哦进程就是它有独立的存储单元对吧
它的存储是完全独立的
然后系统去管理的
而县城的话呢是在竞争之内的
然后呢它实际上是这个共享了这个存储的memory
所以线程写不好
互相内存会打架的对吧
但是县城要比近程强了很多
但这个是windows下的
如果在linux下的话
a进程也可以做的很清亮等等
布拉布拉对吧
但这个确实是个很基本的概念
就是我自己的理解
就是说其实县城的话之间的话
他会share很多这个memory的
这个memory就是我们数据交换通道吧
精神之间的话
实际上你要通过特殊的机制才能彼此去交换信息
所以这个是我们所有的并行化编程的一个foundation基础
那么这个时候呢实际上我们就要去做multi tasking
就是说我既然有那么多盒
我就让他同时处理很多很多事情嘛
这样大家去回想一下
在前面这些课程中
我们讲的游戏引擎的话
大家有没有发现
其实游戏引擎要做的事情其实特别的多对吧
我要做动画
我要做物理
我要做逻辑对吧
我还要做一些rendering的表现
所以其实这个时候我就是multi tasking的
那你如果有四个核
八核16核
我非常的开心
我就用起来
那这么多tasking他在一起怎么去管理呢
这里面就讲到了两个很经典的模型
一个模型的就是preemptive multist tasking
就是抢占式的多任务诶
这个就是操作系统的
哎呀这个我我真的不知不觉地进入了大学操作系统课的这个模式了
同志们
原谅我一下
我接下来要给大家发linux源代码了
我觉得那个时候我们还要去一边学操作系统
一边要读一段linux源代码
给老师写个报告
说证明我真的读懂了
我看得懂这个是怎么回事
好那这个preemptive multitasking的意思就是说抢占式的
就是说当这个县城在跑的时候
诶
或者这个任务在跑的时候
调度者如果认为你该出去了
他就把你调出去了
过一会儿再把你调回来
这个东西是调度者自己决定的
比如说我有一个high priority的事情来了对吧
我就要打断你
我调个中段哥们儿
你出去
然后我再进来
那这个过程的话呢
这个听上去很霸道
但是大家仔细回想一下我们的操作系统
比如说windows操作系统它是什么性质
它就是抢占式的
因为你我不可能让你一个进程
把我的这个整个所有的系统资源全吃光了
那我操作系统本身怎么跑呢
对不对
所以这也是一个比较常见的一种方式
那么另外一种呢就是那个nperimati
就是说非常难吃的marketca
他的意思就是什么呢
哎你居然说你干活
我不会主动打断你
除非你自己说你自己结束了对吧
那这样的东西呢
其实它的好处是什么呢
就是你对它的运行值
如果所有的任务都是你给的话
其实你的控制能力是很强的对吧
但是它的缺点是什么呢
就是万一你写坏了对吧
你一直把我的东西站在这
那我们其他所有人都被迫要去等着你
那这种东西其实在操作系统中实际上是很少用的
但是呢其实在有一些这个非常我们就是real time
那个要求非常高的操作系统里面
也会采用这种非抢占式的这种多任务模型
那这两个东西呢
实际上对于我们整个就是说这个做我们的多线程系统来讲的话
这是两个两大基础对吧好
那既然有这样的一个东西
我们就意识到一件事
就是说诶我们可以启动很多的线程对吧
那么县城和县城之间
他如果在不断的被打断
在多个任务之间来回切换
比如说我启动了20个thread
但是我只有四个核
那我就意味着我要在这threat之间来回的去切换
对不对
那好那这个切换的时候你会发现这个系统它其实很不cheap
就非常的不廉价
为什么首先一个县城被打断的话
它是掉了一个中段
那这个中段呢至少要2000多个cpu的cycle对吧
想想最快的a l u就是最快的指令
只要一个cycle对吧
但是呢大部分是不会不止一个一个circle
但是2000多个circle实际上是很慢的诶
这个时候你如果因为你要去把占空间切换出去对吧
你要把计算机切换出去
那这个时候你会发现你掉进来的县城的时候
他这个数据并不在它的各级缓存里面
它的要去从内存里面再去调这些数据的时候
那这个时候他的时间可能会从1万甚至到100万的这个circle之间
去这个这个delay
所以大家这里面建立一个概念是什么
就是说县城之间的切换实际上是很贵很贵的
这也是后面我们讲为什么job system它的设计就是fiber base
就是那个job system
它是有道理的
就是他意识到这件事情其实是非常的expensive
今天讲的东西稍微有点硬核啊
我会被迫
然后讲很多硬件是怎么操作的
操作系统怎么操作的对吧
大家甚至要理解各自的cash
但没关系
大家这个先姑且一听
然后呢以后大家一边学一边自己写代码
一边就能感觉到
所以这其实是这个paralpmi我们经常会遇到的这样一个问题好
那其实呢在我们在写这种病性化编程的时候呢
我们一般来讲就是有两种不同的
就是多线并行化的这个这个开发的问题
第一类问题呢实际上是非常简单
就是说ok你这些现车我不打断你对吧
你该做你做就做完
我不会把让你停下来
那这样的好处就是它不会有这个threat interaction或thread
thread swapping的这样的问题
那这种问题呢它就是一堆独立的问题
它各自算完
然后大家一起收口这个模型的话呢
其实最简单的一个案例就是蒙特卡罗积分对吧
我就是每一个负责撒1000个采样点对吧
然后我采一个100万个采样点
哎我这个事情就做完了
对不对
这挺好的
这个就他们这样的话呢
其实不会遇到那个就是thread swapping的这个瓶颈
但是呢其实在真实的游戏的这个案例里面的话
我们没有办法把一个游戏所做的模拟分得那么清楚
那我们彼此之间各个就是surprise之间有很多数据的这个依赖
还有什么呢
还有一种依赖关系叫dependency
就是说诶我得等你这个事情做完之后
我才能启动我的事情
所以这个时候就会导致这个program parallel program变得非常的复杂
这个大家如果有一点点的经历写过多
就是那个就是说并形化编程的时候
这是大家一定会遇到的问题
那这个问题怎么解决呢
其实呢有在这里面的话呢
首先你要理解就是这里面会产生的问题是什么
其实最容易出的问题就是dracing
就是什么意思
就是说同一个数据
当一个县城在读它的时候
另外一个线程正在改变它
而且你如果这个逻辑判断是我读完
根据它的一个值
然后我再去做一个做一个操作的时候
很可能你读的时候是一个值
当你在对它进行操作的时候
那个值已经被修改了
另外一个值了
那么这两个东西是不是就有问题了
就像大家有没有试过
就是比如说三四个小伙伴一起在墙上
就是大家一轮流的
其实他们写的东西对吧
其实你看到的和你打墙写的东西是完全不一样的
这个data ring的话呢
实际上是围绕着所有的b计划编程的一个核心问题
产生的这种死锁
产生所有本都都是这件事情为核心的
那么这个时候呢其实最简单的做法是什么呢
哎我们做一个叫这个这个blocking的这个方法
就是说其实这里面有一个词叫critical section对吧
就是以前我们在学多边那个就是学操作系统的时候
一开始老师跟你讲什么叫critical section
然后我就想哎呀
这是个这个critical section
就是很重要的很艰难的部分对吧
critical这个词英文直接翻译过来就是这个这个这种感觉嘛
那其实呢它本质上讲的就是这一段代码对吧
我进去了
直到我出来
你们不要捣乱对吧
你必须要让我完整的执行完
其他人都不许去执行这同一个点
就是在别的线程里面
这段代码不能够被同时重复执行
这样他就能保证当所有的人
比如说我们有计数器
比如说每个人都会啊注册学生对吧
然后我们现在有个count叫学生的account
然后呢学生我要塞入到一个数据库的表里面
那这个这个学生呢抗的增加的时候对吧
如果我的数据库是个单线程的话好
那我们每个人去往数据里面塞东西呀
我就通过一个mutex把它全部控制住
那其实这个critical section的话呢
在这个现代的编程语言里面有很多种实现方法了
比如说有这个真的显示的定义叫critical section
也可以通过mutx对吧
还可以通过什么cm four这些东西
就是那个都能够去解决
叫信号量我都能去解决它
但是呢这样的一个东西的话呢
它实际上是一种阻断式的编程
诶
不好意思啊
我怎么觉得我现在在讲这个哎真的在感觉在像讲操作系统啊
大家原谅我
我我好像回到了大学这个讲操作系统课的这个模式
而且我觉得我讲的很不好
因为一般来讲操作系统这一节讲到这个的时候
老师会差不多一节课的时间给你讲这些东西
而我大概只有几分钟的时间给大家点一些这些概念
那我今天把重点还是放在后面
那么其实呢就是说这样的一种阻断式的这种变形化编程呢
它会产生一个比较严重的问题
第一个呢会产生死锁对吧
大家想想看
就是说诶我再写一个变量
我在等个变量
其实很容易产生思索
另外一个问题是什么呢
这个问题其实是蛮头疼的
就是说呃我们假设并行化变成我同时启动了
比如说几十个甚至上百个任务
其实在真正大型系统的时候
你并不能保证这些task他一定会成功
有些task甚至写的会自己死掉
那么这个时候如果有一个task failure的
甚至crash了
它会导致整个系统的思索
这件事情是很难去
就是如果写代码的时候不小心的时候
很多时候就会出现这种很严重的问题
实际上当有一些更高优先级的任务进去之后
按照目前的这个调度的算法
它其实是不会被打断的
所以说你的高优先级的东西很难去去去打断它
所以这也是因为你一旦进入critical section
它实际上是被彻底保护住的
所以你在这个lock的这种方法的话呢
有的时候你就会出现
就是说你很难去动它
所以这是一种很古典的一个架构
那但是当我去架构一个很大型的系统的时候
其实lock就有个简单的做法
叫你lock尽量不用要用
它是越少越好
待会我们讲的那个job system时候会讲的就是这个东西我会用
但是会用的非常非常的少
ok好
那接下来的话呢其实有一种叫lock free of编程了
他其实想法很简单
就是说既然你有些亮
他很敏感
我也怕大家所有人去改变难度怎么办
我把它变成叫原子性操作
原子性操作其实很神奇啊
就是说实际上它是一个在硬件和底层支持支持的一个东西
其实我刚才也没搞清楚
就是cpu到底怎么实现这件事
但是他确实是在硬件底层去实现了这样一件事
他能保证就是说你对这个变量的读写操作实际上是这个非常的
这个就是说不会被多个任务同时侵占
那这里面有两个概念
一个就是说诶我对数据从那个内存中读出来
我去看这个数据多少对吧
漏漏到我一个
比如说跟我read安全的这样的一个存储空间
我去看他一眼就漏了他诶
或者说呢我要写进去
就是往那个就是那个那个计算机里面或者那个memory去写
它就load和save
实际上是原子性操作的一个很核心的概念
其实说实话我最开始的理解的时候
lodc store
load store这个数据对我来讲还是有点抽象的
有的时候
那么其实呢这里面有很多的概念
但听着都很高大上
比如说arm w对吧
就是你read modify and r就是a你去读它的数据
你去修改它的数据对吧
你还可以去写进去这个数据
但其实有的时候我们要做cs对吧
就check and这个这个这个就是store
就check
我还还去啊set去改变它
所以这里面有一系列的原子形的指令
但是它具体核心的想法就是说你不需要把一整段代码给它锁住
因为这段代码里面如果有崩溃啊
有什么样的问题
你控制不住
但是我只是在一个绝对保证能够执行下去的这个一个一个指令里面
去保证对这一个内存的数值
比如说是integer也好
是个布尔也好
我对它的操作是具有原子性的
一般来讲是个integer了
所以其实呢这个是我们那个在做这个就是说啊多并行化编程的时候
用的另外一种方法
而是用原子性操作来去实现它
那么这里面其实啊就是当我们去真的去实现一个闭性化操作的时候
你一般看到的如果大家知道有很多这种抓抓抓你的那个硬件啊
抓你的那个系统providing的这种软件
你会看到一些很很就是如果你有很多个盒的话
你会看到一张图
这张图会让你很有压力
比如像我们这种强迫症的话
我比如说我看见我们的引擎跑起来之后
我发现哇我上面有很多的空洞
说明什么呢
说明那段时间我的cpu是在那idol的
他在等着其他的任务在启动
但实际上大家如果在写多线程编程的时候
大概率你会写成这样
所以lock free编程的话
它的好处就是说它能够尽可能的避免死锁对吧
通过这些人进行操作
但是呢因为这些原子变量之间的彼此等啊或者依赖啊
诶他彼此之间会产生很多的空洞
那么另外一种方编程的
但这个是理论上的叫wait free
就是等待几乎为零的这种编程
这种编程的话呢
它事实上是有一套数学的方法
然后呢能保证我在多线程的研发中
我尽可能把所有的cpu资源全部占掉
但是wait free这个编程实际上挺复杂的
说实话我自己都没有完全搞清楚
那么我我就是实际上现在大家能够看到的就是说
如果给你一个非常复杂的系统
你能保证这个系统彼此之间它对cpu的利用率是百分之百
这件事情几乎是不太可能的
到目前为止我没看到一个理论的架构
但是呢你对一个具体的
比如说对一个对战对吧
对一个q对一个队列
你把它对他的操作
你把它变成wait free
这件事情现在在行业里面已经有些解法了
那么如果你对一个性能非常critical的这样的一些应用
比如说我们写那种高频的这种这种通讯协议对吧
那你可能就是要用这种解释这种结构的编程
但这种编程的话呢
它是要需要严格的数学和推演证明
就是他不会产生我们前面讲的各种各样的异常对吧
那所以的话呢就是我觉得对于我们做做引擎的时候
很多时候大家能掌握到lock free这一层就可以了
因为接下来大家看到这些gap啊
在job system里面我们能够相对好的去解决这个问题
那么其实呢在这个多线程里面的问题比大家想象的更复杂一点是什么
就是说我们在写一段代码的时候
我们天然的认为这个代码会顺序的执行下来对吧
lone nine two
比如说我们小时候学的这个语言叫什么呢
叫解释执行语言
我不知道有多少同学真的还写过解释
比如现在的很多脚本语言
有些脚本语言还是解释执行
那么你就可以看到非常清楚的
他一行一行一行一行的这个执行下来
我觉得最早的那个basic语言就是解释性语言
但是当我们去写一些高级语言
比如像c语言或者这些语言的时候
交给现代的编译器
其实编译器编译完之后
你完全不知道他真实的用汇编是怎么去实现的
就是你定义了一个操作
一个在前
一个在后对吧
或者说你这个变量在用它
你你会认为这个变量我先设成了一个一个值
比如说零
然后呢我对这个零进行加一
我后面对它重新设置支持成三
然后呢对三进行简易操作
我还是用a b这两个变量
但实际上编译器很可能会把你优化成两段无序的代码
为什么呢
因为它只要保证你顺序执行下来
它的结果是一致的
他就认为这个是一个有效的变异
但它但这种情况的话
可能在多线程的情况下就会出很大的问题
这里面给大家举个简单的例子
比如说我们写两个线程
第一个我们一开始呢把a这个变量初始化零对吧
b这个变量初始化一
那我们在进程一里面跑的这个函数是什么呢
a我把a等于b加一
那b一开始是什么
b是一对吧
那a就是什么呢
a就等于二了
对不对
然后呢这个时候呢b是我们把它设成零
然后呢我后面做一个循环
我我的我的第二个新县城
我做个什么事呢
就是我现在循环就是当b不等于零的时候
那就意味着必备清零这件事情没有发生吗
那我就持续的循环
直到我b不等于零了
好
b等于零了
b等于零之后
我就assert
我觉得验证我说a等于二这个东西
如果大家去理解一下
假设我们的代码真的按我们想的这个顺序去执行的时候
那我们看到的应该是这样一个结果对吧
你会认为就是当你看到b等于零的时候
a一定是等于二的
对不对
但实际上编译器在编译这个左边的这个方程一的时候
他会认为那个上面那个a和下面那个b是两个无关的变量
他最后出来的b是等于零的
a呢也是等于二的
但是呢它有可能b设为零
会在就是它用一个临时计算器这类次性把这个值设成零了
过一会儿它反应它的输给b
但是a呢会抢先的用那个前面那个b的值的话
另外一个b的值的话设成二了
所以当你去这边去
假设说你看到b等于零的时候
a已经完成了等于二的这个操作的话
实际上这个假设是不成立的
而这种编译器的乱序的话
实际上是在我们写这个就是叫b型化开发的时候
是特别特别容易出问题的地方
就是给大家讲一个非常恐怖的一件事情
就是说我们看到各种各样的这个这个这个就是那个意见
比如说啊从我们的pc x86 架构对吧
到这个power pc
然后呢再到这个就是我们的arm的架构
实际上很多cpu它其实并不能保证
你一定按照你的这个代码的顺序依次执行下来
而且特别像arm架构
它是非常追求功耗和性能的
所以它要追求就是尽量的简单
所以它实际上当一段
比如说你写了一个100行的函数对吧
编译器分析完之后
把你的函数框框切成大几段
然后这里的变量一通乱替代对吧
它最终保证结果是一样的
然后呢最后这个结果就出来了
但是呢当我们人天然的去理解你这个函数执行顺序的时候
你会认为前面第一个section做完之后
我就会做第二个section对吧
那么第二个section是基于第一个39
这没有问题
但是你在另外一个县城里面
假设这件事情的发生也是section one
section b
section two的话啊
second three的话
那你就完蛋了
所以同学们如果在做这个移动端开发的时候
会遇到这样一种情况
就是说诶我有时候在pc的模拟器上
我的这个代码跑起来完全没有问题
为什么我的真机上就突然down的死去活来
其实就是这个原因
而且这一点的话
其实在新一代的c加加的语法中
好像我没记错
好像是c加11吧
其实你可以显示的要求说编译器要确保这些东西的执行顺序是一致的
但是呢你所付出的代价是什么呢
实际上是它的执行性能会变得更差
那为什么编译器它会把你乱序呢
因为实际上大家如果对现在cpu的原理
这个我后面也会提到
就是现在cp的原理是这样的
就是说我实际上要从内存中反复地读出你的数据和指令
那么有的时候啊他这个cpu速度是很快的
就是我会就是他总是会饥饿的等着数据
所以呢现在cpu的话
他有的时候它不会等着你的指令一条条执行
根据你的指令在决定
从那时候读数据
他恨不得把一个就是一大段函数
一整块的
就是切成很多块
一股脑扔进去
就是你的指令和数据同时在里面运行
这样它的结果才会快
所以现代编译器基本上也是按照这个原理去优化的
但是呢它所带来的问题就是说在单线程的情况下
你不用去
就是这就是为什么大家去玩那个在做那个开程序开发的时候
我们有一个版本叫release版对吧
我们还有什么debug版
大家会发现debug版有个特点是说你的函数执行的时候
基本上你可以认为它的顺序是对的
但是你一旦到release版的时候
诶
其实它的最后编译出来的汇编和他的执行逻辑
可能跟你想的完全不一样
而且呢我反正我们自己这个有很多很惨痛的
这个我个人有很多很惨痛的经验
就是说如果你去写一个多线程的这样的一个代码的时候
在debug版诶
你发现没有什么问题对吧
逻辑都很成立
一堆246写得很开心
但是你一旦写成这个release版
变成release版的时候
经常会莫名其妙的就挂掉了这个
而且这种bug是非常难查的
因为你根本不知道编译器的优化是什么样的
所以其实当我们在进行这种就parallel programing的时候
实际上这也是一个大家必须要建立起来的一个基本常识
就是说其实一段函数在这个cpu中执行
它是乱序的
那你就不能假设这些变量的值符合你writing下来的那个顺序
那么知道了这些基础的常识
那接下来就回到我们课程的这个正题了
就是那在游戏引擎中
我们怎么去做这个parallel programing呢
对吧
我们要怎么做framework
那这里面的话呢其实最简单的做法
这也是大部分现代游戏引擎的一个做法
就是很简单
我们就把这个每一项任务分到一个thread rendering
果然rendering的事对吧
simulation
比如像物理啊这些东西我都放在这
然后呢哎我逻辑一个县城一人一个县城
大家井水不犯河水
那么彼此之间的通讯呢也是在就是这个这个每个fm开始的时候
我们交换一下数据
其实大家如果看一些比较古典的这个游戏引擎的话
很多都是这样一个架构
这个架构其实挺好使的
基本上你在比如说2~4个盒吧
或者说这种情况下
这个架构其实真的很好
而且你可以摘得非常的清楚
但是这样的一个架构它会有什么问题呢
就是说你其实很难保证
就是说诶我这四个thread大家的就是在workload是一样的
有的有的thread a workload很轻
很快就结束了
但是没办法
我只能等对吧
有些thread呢他work load很大
你得等着他
所以说这是个木桶效应
就是所有人都等着那个最慢的那个worrid完成他的任务
我这我这一天才能结束
那同学们会说那很简单啊
如果是这样的话
我们要不要把这个这个这个比较重的workride把它拆掉对吧
把它给那些很轻的workri
这件事情呢其实非常的复杂
很难
为什么呢
两件事情
第一个就是说这里面牵扯到了数据的访问的这个locality
就是我尽可能一个thread访问的数据是在一块地方
比如说像rendering
我们希望rendering的数据就是集中在一起的
你不能说诶我这个对rendering的这个基础数据的访问
记得render read里面我看到simulation thread有空
我就把它再放到session read里面
那完蛋了
那这个这个数据的访问有时候就会出现data ring的这个问题
就是因为你这些数据全在一个这个threat里面去读写的话
它是安全的
但是你多个threat同时对这一块数据进行读写的话
刚才前面讲了那么多东西
大家知道这是很麻烦对吧
所以说你很多时候这个数据你没办法去分
第二点是什么呢
就是说ok其实对于一个游戏来讲啊
对于不同的场景
其实是每个thread它的负载是完全不一样的
比如说就以这个游戏为例
你有的场景他是渲染特别在某些环境下渲染特别慢
诶到另外一个环境下的话呢
哎因为游戏里的角色和敌人特别多
我的逻辑我的什么东西忙不过来对吧
而这个东西它全是在一个游戏里面
你不能说根据这个我在玩到游戏的不同阶段
我把这些threat的分工做一些动态的调整
那这个的话会导致更多的bug
所以说对于这种固定的这种多线程的这种架构的话呢
它其实就有这样的一个问题
这也是为什么就是说你如果大家去看固定作用这架构的这个providing
看起来它总是会有大概我的感觉
至少有1/3左右的计算资源是会浪费掉的吧
但这个数据不一定准
因为这只是个经验数据
那么另外一种思路是什么样的
我们叫做 join
什么意思
就是说我明白就是我要分这么多的这个thread
动态的调整很很难
但是呢诶我发现一件事情
就是在游戏计算中
有些东西它的一致性非常高
但是呢它计算量很大
比如说动画对吧
大家大家在前面那个动画课里面学到动画的结算
大家会知道那个动画其实是非常复杂的这种重复的运算
它一下子有很多的一些平衡
方程的这个这个那个那个就是那个线性代数啊
这些方程的这些这个矩阵啊
这些运算
所以的话这些运算全部可以把它分开来
那这个时候呢其实就有一个pattern叫做 join
就是说我到了一定时候
我的那个固定好的线程
扔到哪
扔到我们的叫works read
我们预先会申请好一些工作的thread
做完之后呢
这些thread诶我又把它收回来
我就收起来
然后就放到我的结果里面去
所以这个架构呢其实大家如果看现在的
比如说像很多游戏就基于unreal
基于unity这个引擎的话
他基本上做的就是这个focking join的这个方法
这个方法的好处就是说诶我能够相对充分的利用你的多核算力资源
你这个时候是四个核也好
你是八个核
你是六核
我都能相当的把你利用到
但是呢就是说他一定还是有很多的这个大家从这个图上就能看出来
有很多地方还是空的
对吧对了
我刚才忘了讲了
就是固定的那个thread的那个方法呢
他一个最大的问题是
比如说你一上来分了四个thread对吧
你这时候如果遇到了一个双核的电脑怎么办
其实你就很尴尬了
对不对
那你只能是把这些thread两个thread在一个和尚来回的竞争
当然讲了thread来回切换怎么样会很慢
对不对
那还有一种情况呢
这是一个幸福的烦恼
就是玩家配了一个八核16核的电脑
你这个时候不能够游戏引擎
根据这种情况再去把这个虽然分布在动态的去改制是不可能的嘛
因为你很难去第八个这个事情
所以呢那你就眼睁睁地看着那么多的计算资源放在那儿
你用不了
所以大家可以看到有很多游戏啊
虽然说你配了一个很高配的电脑
配了很多的盒
但是它就是你感觉游戏已经卡住了
但是呢你很多计算机cpu资源是没有被占用住的
其实就是这个原因
那么像这个 join的这个模型呢
它会能缓解这个问题
因为他的workread的话的数量
其实很多时候跟你操作系统说你有多少盒给我
那我就把它开在这儿
所以就相当于说你有这些工人
我不用白不用
我就把你用起来了
所以这个方法的话呢
它实际上比它的适应性要比这个固定thread要稍微好那么一点点
但是呢它所带来的问题
就像我们讲的
就是说它实际上还是有很多的工作
他非常难以去balance
他还是在中间产生了很多的gap好
其实呢这个架构呢实际上是一个很经典的架构
去比如意大家去看虚幻的话
它实际上就有两种thread
一种叫name read
他就很明确的告诉你说这是for游戏逻辑的
这是for rendering对吧
大家如果在循环
你们可以看得很清楚诶
他还有很多的这个那个working threat
它就是比如说把物理啊
我可以扔到这些threat上
把它整个去展开
就是大家如果看一个虚幻做的游戏的话
你用那个profi攻击抓抓出来的图大概就是这个样子的
所以这个forehand join的话呢是一个比较呃
怎么说呢
比较清晰
也比较鲁棒的一个架构
实际上如果大家对多线程的要求没有那么高的话
这也是一个非常好的一个架构好
那么实际上的话呢在多线程中的话呢
第三种方法呢就比这个要复杂一点了
join
它其实是一个数展开来再收回来
对不对
但实际上还有一种更复杂的就是叫那个task graph
就是以前在有一个很著名的s d k t v b对吧
就是我可以创建很多的任务
我把这些任务呢设置好他们的dependency
然后呢我一下子扔给这些核去处理
然后呢这些盒可以自动的根据我这些任务之间的dependency
去决定哪个先执行
哪个后执行
而且呢哪个能够并行执行这个东西
其实大家想想看
如果今天我们是在做一个多线程的这样一个系统的时候
这是一个很自然我们认为就应该发生的事情
确实是这样
但是的话呢对于游戏这个scenario来讲
这个任务这点东西是非常重要的
为什么呢
因为游戏它所创建的大量的计算任务是有dependency的
所以的话呢你确实你要用多核方法去运行它的时候
你又不想把这些任务写死在
比如说哎task 2
我就把你扔到the read
他三我就把你扔到这个animation thread
实际上的话呢你必须要构建这个dependency gram
所以现在很多引擎你们用的也是这样一个技术
那这个task graph它怎么做呢
其实比大家想象的要简单得多
很淳朴
你看他就在你代码里面
这个当然现在你可以用普通方法来很多
说什么代码的方法
就是我一个一个的link去构建
比如说诶我先表示说我task一的dependency是这个下一个是task对吧
我task一的下一个是task 3
然后呢一个标记下来
最后呢你把这些dependency这些依赖关系其实全部做好之后
它就形成了下面的这一张图
然后呢这个系统拿到这个图之后
它就可以执行下去了
其实非常简单
但是呢这个task graph它一个问题是什么呢
就是说其实他并没有这个就是说它的这个task这个树的构建
对于很多的技术来讲
第一个它是不透明的
第二个的话呢它很多说假设这个task是执行了完一之后我才能执行二
但实际上在我们真实的游戏引擎里面发生的事情是什么呢
就是经常我一个任务执行到一半
我突然发现哎我得还得做很多很多的事情
我才能把这个任务做完
大家想想看
比如说我要做一个角色的动画对吧
做到一半我突然意识到说我得先做完他的一些
比如说物理
我甚至会fork出一些就是它的这个伤害检测等等这些东西
然后这些任务完成之后才能回到我的身上
所以大家如果看一个真实的游戏引擎里面这个这些任务的话
他们彼此是在运行中不断的创新
不断地设置越来越复杂的这种dependency
而task graph这样一个静态的方式
它有两个很大的问题
第一个就是说它在动态不断的增加这些节点的时候
实际上是非常的复杂
第二件事情的话呢
就是说它早期的版本里面并没有实现一个就是a我做到一半
我要等其他的事情做完之后
我才能继续走的这个东西
这个东西必须要靠后面的系统才能解决
所以呢经讲了这么多了
我们差不多讲了半个小时
我们才能回到我们今天的第一个主角就是job对吧
这个是现代游戏引擎里面大家用的比较这个弹的比较多
而且呢也有引擎在实践的这样的一个东西
那首先讲这个job system之前
我们先讲一个概念叫携程core routine
哎呀这个词听上去还是很高大上嘛对吧
这个携程呢实际上是一个什么呢
非常清亮的一个就是啊
这个这个叫什么叫叫做多线程的一个执行的一种上下文的一种方式
诶这个听上去这个听上去很不像讲人话了
简单来讲就是说我一个函数执行到一半
我可以调一条指令叫做医药的
医药的意思就是英文就是让道的意思
就是说诶我是应该一半
我要等别的事情发生
我把我的执行权让过去
然后过一会儿的话
诶别人再把我再去invoke
把我激活对吧
哎我又激活了
我又可以继续按照刚才那个东西去执行下去
大家想想这件事情是不是很有意思对吧
那如果我在c语言里面
我们写一个函数对吧
那我执行到一半
我突然发现这个打个比方吧
比如说我现在是这个讲一个比较大好理解的例子啊
假设我是一个学生
我要去学校报名对吧
我这个我去准备报名的这个事情做到一半的时候
我突然发现我缺了材料
那怎么办
我得去先把我这事让一下
我要去先找打印机去打印
我玩我所有的报名材料
我才能走下面的流程
那打印机打印不是说你要打当场就能打
对不对
那打印机他自己你要去要的出去让打印机打完
直到打印机打完我的材料之后
我才能回来
继续进行我下面的操作
所以携程它的核心就是这个原理
就是你虽然在做一个任务
但这个任务中间的话我能让道出去
过一会儿别人回来的时候
我还能能回来
那么这件事情的话呢
其实在现代的很多的高级语言里面
是特别是并行化编程里面
比如说像那个应该go语言本身原生态就支持了
对不对
比如说c sharp里面这些概念就用的特别多
因为当我有这样的一个结构的时候
我去写一个变形化的编程的东西
就会非常的方便
但是非常的遗憾
就是说在c加加里面
携程这件事情就很蛋疼
我待会我解释为什么这个事情很头疼好
那么其实呢携程相对于县城来讲的话呢
有一个很大的区别
就是说县城呢是一个调硬件的中断对吧
那整个硬件的这个中段
他的那个站啊
他的所有的这个环境啊
context全部会重置一遍
所以它它的成本其实非常高的
大家如果对这个性能有所了解
你们就知道在线程之间切换的时候
其实操作系统成本是非常非常高
但是我最后我也长头跟大家讲
而携程呢其实它一般是由程序自己来定义的
而且呢它一般在一个read里面
我可以把很多个携程之间来回切换
就是从从cpu来看的话
这还是一个sr没变过
从来没掉过终端
但其实是我们自己的程序逻辑
让它之间可以换来换去
所以呢实际上这里面你根本没有激活kernel的switch
因为线程切换为什么那么贵
你要不断的去调一个中断
是整个kono级的东西
不就操作系统都知道这件事了
你想这事就麻烦了对吧
就像你平时给你的小伙伴换个座位对吧
你们说作业我们俩互相换一下
你们自己商量一下
这事就完了
但是如果这件事被你教导主任发现了
你觉得这事儿就很麻烦了
所以携程和线程的区别就在于就是说县城它是这个公事公办
那个就是整个系学校系统全部报备
而携程是什么呢
就相当于我们在在读书的时候
我跟我的同桌商量一下
我们俩把座位自己换换对吧
这个事情诶叫我老班主任是发现不了的
也不需要向学校报备
所以而且呢我们可以今天画到这
明天放到哪
随便我们根据我们的需求
但这样的话实际上就会让整个的overhead下降非常多
那么县城呢它其实比有两大的这个实现方啊
那个quot就是那个携程
它有哎呀
我觉得可挺好一点吧
老师现在现场我会叫叫错的
就是chroutine
实际上有两种类型
一种是什么呢
叫stuck for
就是有状态的
我有站的
大家想想看一个函数执行到一半
诶
这里面函数里面有什么
有很多local web
对不对
还有很多计算机状态
比如说我现在这里面定义了一个本地的变量
比如叫a a5
哎算算到现在刚刚算到了100对吧
接下来就a加一了
这个时候你跟我说掉了个页的行啊
没问题
过一会儿我回来的时候
我这个a的这个所有的这些变量是不是要全部智慧了
但是大家想想看
就是说其实在这个就是计算机语言里面
你这个东西你函数跳跳出去了没问题
但是那个时候又有其他的函数来了
那个占空间别人就要用掉了
那你这时候站怎么去恢复这件事情其实非常的难
但是呢如果你从编程的角度来讲
就是程序员写代码的时候
你会天然的认为我要的后面我从医药的地方再回来的时候
实际上我的所有的local variable
我所有的计算器全部都应该不会被污染
否则这个代码就非常的一个逻辑
写下来就非常的难
就像上次我跟大家讲的就是rpc的道理一样
就是为什么会有rpc这个东西
就是说当你真的去写这个系统的时候
你会天然就是我们人的大脑对一个事情业务逻辑的理解
天然的就是会一次记录下来
举个例子
还是以刚才那个学生报名的这个例子啊
就是说你可能前面先去要来了
你的学号对吧
你要来的你的班级号
ok这个时候你打算打印你的申请表格的时候
这个时候你要的了
对不对
好这个表格打印回来之后
这个这个表格纸打印回来
开始你要去填写了诶
你其实天然的assume
就是说我知道我的学号和我的班级号
但是记住在你完成这个报名这个任务里面
这个学号和班级号是你本本地的一个web对吧
你的大脑实际上把这个东西记录下来
等你回来
等那张纸拿到的时候
你的大脑a resume
你整个这个corrine
然后呢
他就开始继续往下走下去了
所以其实这个stuck for这件事情非常的关键
就是说我能不能把这个函数执行的所有的context恢复得了
那么相对于stuck for的话
另外一种的话就是stocklist
the cooking
这就是无障无状态的这样的一个口如瓶对吧
那的意思就是我回来了
我不管了对吧
我就认为你前面所有llocal viable对吧
你的所有的计算机全部被清掉了
如果是这么做的话呢
其实这个携程就非常好写
给大家举个例子
比如在c加加里面
c语言里面
你想实现这样的一个无状态的qing怎么写对吧
其实很简单
写一个go to直接从函数里面跳出去了
然后你有本事再跳回去
你整个状态就全错掉了
对不对
但这个事情就是我建议大家轻易不做这个
因为其实他有很多很多的问题
但是呢stuck is cooking它的好处是什么呢
就是说它的实施起来相对来讲比较简单
但是的话呢他对这种quot的开发者来讲要求非常高
而且他一旦写不好
它就会产生大量的bug
其实我在这里给大家顺便讲一下
就是游戏引擎开发的一个核心的一个挑战是什么
不是说我的技术越高端越好
实际上一个游戏引擎它只是一个基座
当我们去做一个不同的游戏产品的时候
上面做应用的时候
很多人会基于你的接口进行开发
那么如果你对这个开发者要求特别高
比如他要非常能清晰的理解这种并行编程的各种坑的话
那基本上这个引擎是没人能用的
因为大家知道这个挑战太大了
对不对
所以游戏引擎有个很重要的任务
就是把这个困难留给自己对吧
把最难的东西留给自己
然后呢对于开发者来讲
你能写这个简单的代码
能解决的问题
尽量用简单的代码
你能用脚本写完的是最好
脚本甚至不用写
你能连几张图
连几个图片啊
连几个graff就能完成的任务
那是更好
所以说其实的话呢就是像stylist的quotine的话
除非在很底层
我们自己用
否则的话我们会尽量的不用
但是呢就是它并不是一无是处的
因为对于这种无状态的苦入性
它一个很大的好处是什么
你不需要再去保存和恢复整个站啊和local register的这样的一个状态
所以说如果这些非常高频的代码
然后呢它又是底层
就是只有少数几个很核心的同学去写的话
那其实你用stuck city也是一种方法
但是只是说写这个代码的同学水平要求非常高
这个地方讲起来就有点硬核了
大家仔细体会一下好
那实际上哎我就我已经把两个比较已经写完了
讲完了
实际上确实就是这两个东西无所谓高下
但是呢就当我们作为一个引擎
我想做一个高度并行化的一个引擎
让所有的程序员
就是游戏开发程序员也能享受这种并行化的乐趣的话
那我们会非常强烈的推荐
就是是就使用这种有状态的quoting
stuck
foot
quoting name stucklist quotine的话呢
我们会建议就是说用在非常底层
只有少数人控制的
而且是非常native code
甚至你惹急了
你写汇编也没有问题对吧
但是呢cine有一个很大的一个难点是什么
就是说其实在这个就是说不同的操作系统下
就是语言
就是native语言
比如像c c加加汇编这些底层语言
特别是c和c加加
它其实并不支持chrot这个机制
就比如说我们在这个windows下对吧
我们想实现quoting
这里面有一些方法
比如说用boost boost有一套底层机制
它实际上是能帮你实现cking这种机制的
但是呢如果你仔细读它的代码
你发现它其实里面调用的是汇编是吧
就我调用了中段
我还得啊也没有调用中断
但是我要把那个这个这个register寄存器啊
我要把战战堆栈全部给它导出来
那个占的大小你还得设置
就是说我要一上来告诉作系统
说诶我这个这个系统
我这我这个程序每一个函数它的占空间多大对吧
有的占空间你设置小了
你的函数写着写着就占空间炸掉了
大家如果写过递归的代码的时候
清查或者有些函数这个局部变量又申请了太大的时候
你们会遇到一个问题叫占空间爆炸
但是大家如果只是写一些什么python呢
或者h2 f语言
你可能很少遇到
但是如果大家写c加的同学会遇到这种情况好
那占空间如果设置的小了怎么办呢
对小了
首先我的性能
比如说我的我的stock for quot出去的时候
那肯定性能会高嘛
因为我把这些这一段占空间对吧
把它拷贝出去保存起来
在内存中保存起来
在最后再恢复肯定是快的
但是呢诶哦如果是大了的话
如果是大了的话
就是那你每一次的quotine yeld和他的这个resume
实际上它的成本就会高
所以你会发现很有意思
就是当你去写这样的一段系统的时候
其实你就要对对操作系统的调度的底层
在内存中怎么去分配的
它的数据怎么存的
代码怎么存的
你要理解得非常的清楚
那么而且这个事情非常蛋疼的一件事情是什么呢
就是说你的这一套quot的底层实现机制在windows平台下对吧
在那个playstation playstation好像是有native的去支持quartet这个东西
哎这是好消息啊
好像我如果没记错
好像是这样的
哎呀不好意思
这好像是保密的信息
我就不讲了
那么那但是呢就是在那个就是说比如说在arm base的这个芯片上面的话
好像是你要自己通过一段汇编去实现这个类似于cor
肉体的这样的机制
但是好消息就是说这个这些方法怎么去实现的话
其实在网上有很多的很好的一些样例对吧
大家实在不行
参考一下boost也能知道怎么做
所以的话呢这个是这个quotine
特别stuck for the quoting的话呢
是在我们的游戏引擎
我们在构建很多基础的时候
它是我的一个foundation基础好
那么你有了这样一个就是
比如说你有一个stuck for cooking这样的东西的时候
接下来我们就开始我们有趣的东西了
这个东西听上去非常的高大上啊
叫fiber base job system
fiber这个词呢呃怎么说呢
就是说叫管道叫光纤对吧
fiber英文光纤好像也是fiber对吧
那么这个词其实还是蛮高大上的
这是windows的一个概念
为什么我对这个词特别有感情呢
因为就是十几年前
当我在美国去学架构下一代的引擎
就那个时候我们在架构design引擎的时候
我们那时候就想要加这个多线程高度并行化
所以我们就会研究fiber这个技术
所以这个词我也觉得特别的酷对吧
其实fiber你可以理解成就是说我们架构一个就是非常高速的
这个就是说一个一个一个一个一个进程管一个一个县城管道
然后呢我们可以在这里面高速的放很多的task
这些task里面可以自由地进行各种croot的这种
就携程的这个切换
那么而在这里面的话呢
就是说我们的很多的任务就可以自由地塞到这个fiber里面去
往里面塞塞塞
然后fiber会不停的去执行
而且我塞进fiber里面的这些任务的话
这些就我们叫做drop对吧
诶它可以设置dependency
而且呢我还可以进行各种priority的设置
他这个想法其实非常的简单
其实大家想想看
当我们去实现一个真正的多线程系统的时候
这个job system是不是我们最理想的情况对吧
原则上来讲的话
你有100个1000个不同的任务
我有十个核好了
你们就大家就纷纷根据每个任务的长短
我去像搭积木一样的凑在一起
尽量确保所有的fiber他的任务是在同一时间进来的
乡间的时间完成
所以这是fiber based the job system最简单的一个想法
那这里面有一个有意思的细节是什么呢
就是哎fiber你可以想象成一个works read
这里面有个workre概念对吧
就是那这个我到底申请多少个mo
比如说我拿到一台我我的游戏跑起来之后
我的引擎跑起来哎
我发现这台电脑有四个核对吧
那我申请多少个works read
那么我假设发现这个电脑有16个核
我申请多少个workra
这里面其实有一个trick
你比较缺口
这是也是那个fiber系统的一个很核心的一个一个思想
就是我尽可能的一个work read对应一个盒
这个盒呢可以是个逻辑盒
也可以是个物理核
一般我们会对应那个逻辑和逻辑盒什么概念
就大家看现在cpu都是什么hyper thread
对不对对吧
它实际上是呃一个盒
但是它逻辑上分成两个盒
一般来讲我们一个hyperread
我们会给它做一个working read
这样的好处是什么呢
就是说当我不停地往这里面去加不同各种各样的job的时候
我并不需要这些thread进行swap
这也是fiber系统最核心的一个思想
就是说我们在这个系统里面
这个thread的这个swap几乎是零
这个是非常重要
因为刚刚刚刚刚大家在前面已经看到了
就是说每一次thread的切换实际上是非常昂贵的
所以哎你看这里面就很淳朴了
对吧啊
那我就知道了
那我有多少个和我就生成生成多少个working thread
而这个时候呢实际上就比较简单了
就是说我们这个walking read
还有叫fiber
对吧
好
我用户生成了一个一个的job的时候
我就把它压到这个fire里面去
我就让你们去依次去执行那thread就是个很working read
就是个可怜的工人
我就开始一个一个执行这些所有的job
那么这里面的话呢
其实注意啊
这个job中间的话其实有两个很核心的概念
第一个就是他们之间是有优先级的
但是我还讲优先级怎么处理
还有一个是什么呢
他们之间是有dependency的
就是说诶有些任务我要完成我这个job的时候
一个joke就它可以fork出来很多其他的jo对吧
那这个时候我最近我这个就是working read
怎么去调度呢
这里面就讲到一个就是首先它有一个global的调度系统
它叫job scheduler
他会你你的job其实并不是直接递给working read
实际上是job scheduler
他会根据每一个walking read
他的这个饱和状态
把这些任务扔进去
所以这个和大家刚才看到就是说比如说那个 join
那个模型应该不大不同
是什么呢
他那个function join的那个模型啊
实际上是它还是一个单线程的
但只是到了一段之后
他突然生成了一大批诶类似的任务
你们做完之后再合到一起
它并不是真正的就是全b性化的这样一个模型
而真正的全面信号模型一定是这样的一个系统
就是说诶我有个schedule对吧
你所有的这个硬件的计算资源对我来讲只是我的resource
都是我的worker
然后呢我来决定说
哎你这个任务大一点
你就把它扔到这儿
你就做得长一点
你任务小一点
我就给你多塞几个小任务对吧
我尽量保证大家的任务基本是均衡的
而这里面就有一个非常有意思的问题了
就是说当我有这样的一个working task的话
我是先认认据的任务先完成的
就是像一个q一样像个队列一样的
first thing first out
还是这个系最后扔进去的任务先执行对吧
last thing first out
这个是什么
是个堆栈
大家想想看这个东西你天然的理解是什么
我相信所有的同学天然的理解都是
那肯定是first in first out嘛对吧
我先生的任务先做完嘛
对不对
后续容才能做嘛
诶这里面就是一个啊
当我们做游戏引擎的drop sister的时候
大家要注意的一点
就是说其实在游戏引擎的工程实践中啊
我们实现我们的job system的时候
一般啊只能讲一般这个东西不一定呢
也许我讲的是不对的
但是一般来讲我们会用last thing first thought
为什么呢
因为在游戏引擎中
很多的job产生的话
都是前一个job做到一半
突然发现我要产生四五个不同的job
而这个job在执行到一半的时候又会产生新的job
所以他彼此之间是个dependency关系
那就意味着说我fork出来的这些任务如果不去完成的话
我的自身是完成不了的
大家想想这件事情是不是这样的对吧
所以的话呢它的实施方法其实是last thing for salt
像个堆栈一样的
就这个很有意思
其实那个就这也是我们在企业去opl特别容易犯的一个错误
好那这个时候呢我们的这些job的执行的时候
实际上是按照一个debeng事情
如果我这个时候发现我的job被药的掉之后
我们就会把那些医药掉的任务呢
我把它全扔到一个waiting list里面去
诶这个事情这个事情谁干
schedule干吧
所以在这个working ride里面
你的任务塞进去了
并不是永久的
只要我会依次的去执行
对不对
但我一旦发现你被要了之后
我就把你框一扔
我就执行下一个可以执行任务
大家想象一下
这样的话是不是我们就可以把这个cpu尽可能的利用起来
对吧
你你要等着你的那些dependence执行完之后
你才回得来才能执行的了
而这里面的话呢还有一个很重要的东西叫job stein
什么意思
就是说在这些walking read里面的话
我堆了很多的jobs
对不对
实际上无论你做最好的再好的skype
你实际上是并不能估计这个任务要跑多久呢
因为有两种情况
第一个这个任务的gb的运算太复杂了对吧
你看的是一个函数扩
但里面你给我算了一堆这个很神奇的这个计算
那我等半天等不了
有的时候我的job是要等i o的对吧
这很疯狂
我的我要等i o画很久
那么还有一种可能性是什么呢
就是说哎你的教育本身不复杂
但是呢你又很你在这个过程中间产生了一堆dependency
或者你天然的就有很多dependency
那就会导致什么问题呢
就导致了就是说我其实没有办法让就是我给你100件任务
实际上scheduler他是没有办法去estimate每个任务要执行的时间的
所以就会出现一定会出现什么呢
就是有些workread他的活已经做完了
有些workread呢还剩下很多活没做完
那怎么办
哎
works read
会schedule
很聪明的把那些没有做完的那些那个那个那个read里面的那些任务
偷过来
放到我们的这个空闲的这个sd里面
大家仔细看
这个想法其实非常的简单
就是job system
它实际上就像有一个工厂里面有一个这个这个经理对吧
他时刻看每个工人手上的活儿
然后这个工人的这段任务的话
实际上呢第一个它又相对独立
但是呢他彼此有一有一赖
比如说我们造一个鞋对吧
有人去刷鞋底
有人去做鞋面
有人在穿鞋带
对不对
还有一些其他的
比如说还有皮鞋
也有凉鞋在一起
那当这么多的任务
这些部件塞过来的时候
这个manager他就会不停地把这些任务堆到这些人前面
然后不停地观察这些工人的状态
然后呢尽量保证每个人手上都有活干
而且呢他尽可能的他用lasting for all的这个方法
尽可能的保证
就是说它的前导工序做完之后再去完成后面的工序
其实啊就是大家讲起来job sim是一个很高大上的概念
实际上说实话job si实现起来还是蛮复杂的
就是对于特别对游戏这种case来讲
但是呢它的最核心的思想就是这些
就是说你其实它是一个更彻底的用多线程的思想
就是用那个parallel programing思想或者多线程就是b型化编程思想
充分的利用了所有的cpu的资源
这个东西我们个人认为就是在未来的话
就是说嗯随着我们的计算机的核越来越多
比如说那x86 架构里面八个和16和32核
那一定是发生的事情
对不对
比如说army base的芯片中
我们的那个盒也会越来越多
为什么
因为我不能够做得太快对吧
我要降低功耗
那这个时候其实job system
实际上还真的是一个未来的一个很重要的一种实施方式
那么job system呢实际上是一个非常好的一个系统吧
就是说他实际上非常容易实现这个任务的这个schedule
而且呢它也能很容易地去处理这些任务之间的dependency
它不像刚才我讲的那个就是tx graph的方法对吧
你要很傻的
在你的这个程序启动之前
要不断地定义这些task
定义它的dependency那个东西大家如果写写就知道就很难受
但是这个东西有没有用的
他graph其实也是有用的
比如说在现在的很多的引擎或者一些平台里面的话
它有些大的模块之前在dependency还真得用中方法去定义下来
但是当我在产生几百个上千个上万个这样的db在一帧里面的时候
实际上只有job system才能够非常高效地解决这个问题对吧
而且呢就是每一个job的这个堆栈它都是独立的
彼此之间不会去干扰
而且呢就是说因为它是基于可如亭的这个架构
而且我们也讲了
就是说每个works read它是对应的一个物理的和
所以的话呢它就不存在这个context switching
因为他只要不触发硬件那个中断的话
它的效率就会非常的高
那么它的挑战是什么呢
就是说首先的话c加加语言natively
它并不支持fiber对吧
你得自己实现一套这个quotine这个机制
但是我刚才讲了
就是说实在不行
用boost对吧
但是你如果嫌boost特别大
你怎么办
你把boss里面的代码给抠出来
其实也是可以的对吧
就是说所以呢它只是在不同的那els平台上
时间的方法不一样
那么另外一个的话呢
就是其实这样的一个系统啊
真正实现起来其实挑战还是非常大的
特别是就是你去实现drop system底层的时候
因为它的特点是什么呢
就是说对于上面的这些可入性的这些业务逻辑的开发者来讲的话
这些对你来讲全部透明了
你看不见的对吧
你觉得诶好像我的任务扔进去了
我只要不停在中间
我说我在fork一个job job就出来了啊
任务数据结果就拿到了
很开心
那么这个任务你就可劲的写
写完之后你去跑起来之后
profile一看
你发现诶这东西就像小砖头一样垒得整整齐齐的很
就是那个job system跑出来的这个系统
providing特别满足这种叫强迫症的患者
比如像我就是个强迫症患者
你会发现那个cpu看着特别的整齐
很开心对吧
就是有种叫拼花拼图的快感
但是呢你真的要去实现这样的一个就是非常鲁莽和稳健的job系统
其实是要求你对这个就是多线程硬件的这个底层开发的话
要非常的了解
举个例子啊
比如说在硬件开发中会产生很多数据racing的challenge挑战
甚至有时会产生一些非常难以这个被发现和debug的这个问题
举个例子
比如说我们内存中分配了一段空间
你在一个县城里面说这个空间我认为无效了
我要把它的内存释放掉
对不对
过段时间我要检测一下这个释放是否成功
如果不成功的话
我就认为这个是我成功了
我就后面把这个东西干掉
如果这个数据没有被分配掉
那被被释放掉
我就继续要的逻辑
但是这时候另外一个线程他发现这段内存空了
他又开始他又产生了一个新的分配任务
有可能那个heap就是那个我们的那个就是heap
就是那个系统管那个那个叫堆吧
heap叫堆
对不对
就是他去分配这个内存的时候
他又把他的那段内存地址又重用了
而且呢他又好死不死的在那个地方放的数值又是一模一样的
好等后面的数据再接后面的逻辑
在另外一个系统的数据在检查它的时候
它发生在你们的数据其实没有变化
他没有检测到这个数据已经变成guid
这个case case叫什么呢
我们叫做a b a case对吧
就是其实你认为就是在一个线程里面
前面一段代码对着数据进行一些修改
后面再去检测的时候
发现它没有变
但是没变了
我的逻辑就就就就是就完全另外一个方向去走了
对不对
但实际上在这个两次中间的话
在另外一个县城里面
我实际上已经把这个数据改过去一遍
我再改回来了
那这个时候其实你的业务就会产生一些非常深刻
就非常深的
非常难以发现的bug
这种bug的特点是什么呢
就是说呃你基本上可能跑几天几夜
然后呢突然你的系统就异常了
就挂掉了
然后呢你几乎没有办法浮现他
因为那个内存分配它是很随机的过程
而且呢它还得随机到叫做那个地方的数据
恰巧又被写回到原来的状态
所以导致你很多的检测函数全部无效
而当我们去真的去实现一个这样的一个对于上层开发者来讲
非常简单好用的这样的一个job system的时候
实际上在底层写它的人的话
一定要非常小心谨慎地把所有的parallel programming可能出现的一些异常
k4 都得要防范掉
否则的话你狠狠的这个系统上线之后
就是说出现了一些就是我们最怕的问题就是什么
就是说诶你如果我们百分之百会当场crush掉的bug
一般来讲对于我们来讲就很开心
说这种bug i crush掉了
比如说q a报上了这东西
crush
我就问第一个问题
说这东西能不能出现
他说能复现
复现率多少百分之百
那我就很开心了
我说你们不要怕这个问题
我们一定能修得好对吧
但是的话呢如果他告诉我说诶我们这个服务器开服了三天之后
有概率突然就挂掉了哇
一般遇到这种问题的时候
我们就很惨
我们真的很害怕
因为其实当我们去实现这样的一个b型化开发的时候
我们实现这样一个drop system的时候
大家一定要注意
就是说千万千万要把你的理论功底
基本功练得足够扎实
然后呢才开始去搭这些底层系统
否则的话你很容易搭出一个看上去很酷的一个东西
但是当一些丰富和复杂的业务逻辑压进来之后
你会在各种很奇怪的地方挂掉
所以呢其实对于这种就是por program
特别它的底层核心系统的话
我会建议大家就多做一些形式化的推导
就是说去从理论上证明这个东西是安全的
而不是完全基于自己的经验去看这东西是不是合理的
另外一个的话呢就是多去网上去查一些资料
就是说实际上比如说像vivi啊
这上面有很多的那个那个那个国外有很多这个开发的这个网站
有很多程序员总结了很多的pattern
就是说当你去并行化的时候
在这个地方会遇到问题
所以说呢虽然我们这节课讲的是高级课
讲的一个就是说诶怎么去实现一个这个非常彻头彻尾的一个
b性化的游戏引擎对吧
用job sim听上去很高大上
我也想去做
但是的话呢就是当大家真的去做这件事情的时候
因为这里面你很可能吭哧吭哧搞了半年
然后呢整个系统挂的在这个四处漏风对吧
这个这也是就是说这个事情的挑战